>>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, LCD
SOUNDSYSTEM!
♪♪
♪ I'M ON FIRE
BECAUSE YOU WANT ME
BECAUSE YOU WANT ME ♪
♪ BUT MY DESIRE
IS GOING TO CRUSH ME ♪
♪ BUT I'M ALL CHILLS
'CAUSE YOU ADORE ME
YOU ADORE ME ♪
♪ BUT I'M STILL ALL KILLS
I NEED MY THRILLS
I NEED MY THRILLS ♪
♪♪
♪ I'M ON FIRE
BECAUSE YOU WANT ME
BECAUSE YOU WANT ME ♪
♪ BUT MY DESIRE
IS GOING TO LEVEL ME
'CAUSE YOU'RE ALIVE ♪
♪ BUT I'M ALL CHILLS
'CAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
LOOSE-KNIT
YOU'VE BEEN LOOSE-KNIT ♪
♪ BUT I'M STILL ALL KILLS
I NEED MY THRILLS
I NEED MY THRILLS ♪
♪♪
♪ I'M ON FIRE
BECAUSE YOU WANT ME
BECAUSE YOU WANT ME ♪
♪ BUT ALL OF MY DESIRE
IS GOING TO CRUSH ME
WHEN YOU EXPIRE ♪
♪ BUT I'M STILL ALL KILLS
BUT YOU WANT ME
BECAUSE YOU WANT ME
I NEED MY THRILLS ♪
♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]